[Musique]
et je voulais dit il y avait deux
événements donc la défaite du psg
evelyne thomas à la présentation de tmp
tout le monde en a parlé
donc qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé ce
que ça a été une bonne ou une mauvaise
idée de ma part est-ce que j'ai déconné
ou est ce que on a fait quelque chose de
bien vous nous dites que vous nous direz
franchement vous avez pensé je prendrais
tout dans la gueule s'il le faut
inquiétez pas c'est pas grave j'ai
l'habitude
allez c'est parti regardez montage à
vous vous dites mais qu'est ce qu'elle
fait en tête pour tous pas comme ça ne
rigole à mes vannes
jean luc moreau d'appréciation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peut m'appeler tout de suite et à torcy
cap daniel martyrs à la maison un bel
espoir de montrer qu'on peut faire une
émission après avoir pris l'apéro
[Applaudissements]
mauvaise idée
vous l'aurez bien sûr y acquérir auquel
bonne élève un cas noté alors qu'ils
aimeront vous dit quoi à pour moi
c'était un naufrage
je fais pas du psg parce que je
m'intéresse pas du tout au foot groupe
dur pour yveline cake est venu qui
connaît pas les missions pour la vérité
bon nom mais elle a son seuil qui
correspond à son public et à son type
d'émission qui est une émission qui
estime monial sur un show comme celui ci
ça allait pas et c'est un vrai naufrage
mais en revanche vous avez inventé un
truc qui reçoit c'est le c'était le
premier bêtisier en direct ça d'habitude
le maîtriser on cherche les séquences et
tout laïcité toutes réunies en direct
dans une émission
et ça c'était drôle c'était une
expérience à vivre c'était une sorte si
elle aura été là je dirais que c'est une
sorte de voile à deux prestations
artistiques
merci alors bon alors vous géraldine
maillet adn louis acide dxo non
ribonucléique très bien merci voyou pas
été précis alors tu vois tu veux faire
la maligne mais j'étais bien mais je
trouve qu'elle a été courageuse à l'aise
ou héroïque
elle a mouillé la carotte et sa robe
noire qui était fort joli mais je te
conseille la carotte de ma wii et
jean-michel ça a été ça a été une
catastrophe
et en fait c'était une catastrophe parce
qu'en fait on a vu grâce à evelyne
thomas et à cause des limites au mas
qu'en fait ici c'était une mécanique
était totalement ciselé pour vous et en
fait tpm pc votre adn le rythme de
l'émission ce sont les battements de
votre coeur et votre cou et même les
vannes elle était écrite pour elle et
vous les vannes vous êtes dans l'impro
vous êtes dans l'intuition et c'est pour
ça que ça marche
et moi j'ai juste vu hier soir outre le
naufrage qu'en fait ils pouvaient pas y
avoir une contrefaçon hanouna maintenant
les jeunes l ai fait d'avoir 100 moi
j'ai trouvé ça très mauvais voilà et
vous demandez c'est dur mais je veux
dire ce que j'en ai pour sérieusement
monsieur c'était votre idée oui c'est
une très bonne idée sur
[Applaudissements]
pour de vrai j'ai regardé en entier et
bien sûr il y avait des loupés mais moi
ce que j'aime chez elle c'est qu'elle
elle dit c'est très important pour un
animateur un animateur elle dégage un
truc extrêmement sympathique sera et tu
la regardes tu ris même quand elle se
bat n'est c'était drôle parce qu'à côté
justement vous vous marquer le fait que
c'était foire et donc les foirade était
drôle c'était en direct y avait une
bonne ambiance et franchement moi j'ai
bien ri et j'ai pas senti ce que vous
disent que vous avez dit sérieux côté
gène ans s'était pas gênant c'était
vraiment vraiment drôle alors évidemment
n'est pas mon coeur qui veut cette
émission elle a été moulé autour de vous
moulé autour de votre corps ça se voit
vallespir arrivera jamais elle est venue
dans un slip qui n'était pas le sien
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que malgré
tout elles sont assez bien des bruits
êtes déjà allé dans un slip qui était
pas sous bois où est la vie d'isabelle
morini-bosc déjà y'a marqué pas la
carotte da c'est vrai que s'il venait à
la cgem n'est pas absolument pas compris
pourquoi et vie n'avait pas ce que je
lui ai mis une carotte gens là je les ai
amenés dans voilà la pauvre gerald city
ni des ailes
alors ça c'est non c'est ce sont des
marrons ça c est on l'entendait pas
surtout temps comme on n'en attendait
pas et c'était quand vous entendez ce
que vous dites toujours escaliers alors
je vous le dis et vers le travail
comique romain son truc à elle veut pas
des niveaux les gravats quand tu étais
trop oui en revanche moi je les trouvais
effectivement si le père courageux
secourir un moment où moi j'aurais dit
bon ça va je rentre chez moi
elle s'est quand même elle s'est
allongée sur le mur aulas fait donc
c'était évidemment pas vous mais pas la
face à lons le saunier du courageux
spectateurs dans ce qu'elle fait et
l'animation nocturne en direct et la
mine hélas pas l'habitude du direct
alors faiblard pour le coup c'était pour
un baptême du feu c'était un baptême du
feu un d'accord monsieur demers moi j'ai
mis très sûr j'ai un triste pour elle
parce que c'est vrai qu'on l'a senti
même avant l'immersion dans les
coulisses elle était résidente est
stressé c'est normal c'est les cdo et
elle s'est laissée déborder comme les
joueurs du psg s'est laissé déborder par
l'enjeu et par le stress
elle a voulu faire du cirill mais on
peut pas faire du cirill dont fallait
faire autre chose elle a pas su faire
autre chose elle était toujours à côté
débordé par l'oreillette débordé par
vous aussi et donc du coup mais s'est
s'inquiété la ville de dakar hydraulique
c'était ça qui était hyper marrant à
détruire tous chantent ils ont dû
elle n'a pas lâché moi j'ai trouvé très
touchant ce nom mais valérie bella
c'était une bonne idée sur le papier
mais votre présence la tétaniser nous
avait déjà alors c'est elle qui a voulu
que ce show là là c'était à mon avis une
erreur dauchy art parce que vous avez
déjà donné l'émission prêter des
missions à des femmes vous l'avez fait
avec inora vela biraben avec moi avec
aude les mange marie audrey pulvar et c
est ça a plutôt bien fonctionné parce
que vous n'étiez pas là en tout cas en
tout cas la pression est moindre quand
les patrons de l'émission quand le
taulier de l'émission n'est pas présent
et évidemment avec moi je suis beaucoup
plus détendu quand mathieu de langue
n'est pas là c'est évident parce qu'en
même n'avait pas effectivement tous les
codes qu'elle était parfois un petit peu
stressé le réflexe qu'on a c'est on se
tourne vers qui celui qui a les codes de
l'émission donc elle se tournait
régulièrement vers vous pour que vous
repreniez la main ce qui fait que le
bateau tanguait trois petits points
ouais ben je n'avais pas le temps
d'écrire donc j'avais trois petits pas
en fait c'est votre idée mais je pense
que vous vous êtes pas rendu compte de
la chose énorme que vous aviez lui
confier entre les mains parce que c'est
du direct
elle en fait mais c'est vrai mais voilà
tout de suite il a laissé des mal
classés celui là je vais même pas pensé
à ça parce que je pense que mais j'ai
trouvé effectivement très courageuse
elle a été elle a été très belle parce
que c'était pas facile moi qui étais
vers vous c'était vraiment pas facile
vous étiez un petit stress et puis ce
que je voulais dire c'est un syndiqué à
votre suite
[Rires]
armstrong est présent parmi les débris
s'étaient invités racines et j'adore
règles mais c'est vrai que hier j'ai
trouvé qu'elle manquait un tout petit
peu de sud de second degré non là pour
voler l aller si elle connaît pas les
missions jure vous êtes hyper dur si on
dirait elle connaît pas les missions
gains des lots et gilles verdez et après
elle est là la mifi rider est donc on va
voir si un rezéen péter tous et avant ce
que je vais dire je précise que je les
adore mais elle est formidable
normal hier c'était presque une tragédie
est en fait j'ai pas du tout compris je
trouve qu'elle est resté dans son coin
elle est pas venu vers nous mais je le
dis aussi nous ne sommes pas
suffisamment aller vers elle et moi le
premier
c'est sûr mais j'ai pas compris je
trouve qu'elle connaissait pas les
missions qu'elle connaissait pas le truc
qu'elle n'était pas dans le match
je trouvais ça très long j'ai trouvé que
c'était pas touche pas à mon poste je
trouve que le programme non mais je dis
ce que je pense à et je les adore voilà
ça a été un peu dénaturé donc je suis
très déçu donc bonne ou mauvaise idée
vous pires idées que j'ai eu de belles
idées oui on est tous d'accord pour
reconnaître le courage et le fait que
evelyne et relever la proposition et
relever le défi soit soit venu
finalement est tenu les deux heures de
direct ça il n'y a pas de souci mais
cyril vous m'avez
complètement scotché devant ma télé
quand vous avez proposé ça appelé le
patron derrière pour demander
l'autorisation qu'est ce qui vous a pris
puisque vous connaissez votre public
vous connaissez cette émission et je
suivais également ce qui se disait sur
twitter et on s'y retrouvait pas quoi ça
prenait à aucun moment alors j'ose dire
si j'avais toujours de bonnes idées ça
sort j'ai très souvent des idées de
merde vous mais là moi je vais vous dire
ce que j'en ai pensé moi je et donc vous
pensez que c'est la pire idée quoi ouais
c'était un peu malaise tv en direct
boily moins de fautes non moi j'ai
regardé un peu et j'avais l'impression
que c'est comme quand tu prennes ton
appart à un pote tu es tu prête et tu
reviens il a foutu la merde tu as tout
le monde peut pas faire des souplesses
comme ton père mais il faut qu'elles
temps mais chacun le fait comme il est
franchement moi je les trouvais moi j'ai
trouvé voilà ce qui m'a fait rire c'est
que yvelines elle n'a pas lâché
elle joue et tous les trucs dès qu'il y
avait un problème elle le jouer elle
était drôle et je trouve que on a bien
fait de le faire
je trouvais que c'était super parce
qu'en fait vous la jolie tout le monde
en a parlé evelyne était super contente
le score d'audience est pas mal du des
banques et qu'elle a fait un million
trois cent cinquante mille
téléspectateurs sont les cibles aller
voilà les bains mal alors et je vais
vous dire bizarrement et et là vraiment
ça vous intéresse et bizarrement evelyne
a beaucoup perdu en fait a baissé par
rapport à la veille mais sur les plus de
60 ans voilà c'est plus de 60 ans qui ne
sont pas venus voir touche pas aux
postes qu'ils sont très nombreux aussi
on a voilà il ya tous les âges qui
toutes les personnes de tout âge qui
regarde tous touche pas à mon poste
et ce sont les tranches les jeunes en
tant qu'usagers qui ne sont pas venus
voir évident lors que les jeunes étaient
là à waimes jure que c'est vrai mais
voilà et donc et c'est laisser les plus
âgés qui est visualisé sinon elle a
battu toutes les autres chaînes sur les
cibles en réalité voilà première tnt
voilà sur toutes les autres outre à ce
que vous avez un sur les bio tchané
mission oui il ya des moments vous
sentiez effectivement que le bateau
n'aurait non mais la fête est la seule à
vraiment à la carte - pour moi la carto
nos audiences et elle a fait le boulot
alors moi il ya une image qui m'a fait
le plus rire hier c'est qui c'est eux
c'est isabelle morini-bosc je me dis de
l'eau sur la table sur l'année
regardez bien cette image elle veut
vraiment me pète a jamais vraiment
j'avais l'air et j'assume
de rires non mais regardez c'est énorme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
real pousse à boire la tasse à thé
mission était folle voilà je ne regrette
pas et voulait remercier evelyne thomas
de l'avoir fait à l'amour yvelines on
t'aime et lundi moi je vais présenter le
mas de mingue à 17h20 ouest et ouais
loyer ou pas on se croise et oui mais si
elle m'avait promis j'ai promis
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise
c'est comme ça alors on va voir ce que
l'on pensait les téléspectateurs ce
qu'on pensait que c'était une bonne ou
une mauvaise idée
alors regardez attention série allez on
va passer à 30
[Applaudissements]
à
vick a toujours raison et son réseau
d'accords de dictateurs africains
reste à savoir s'ils vont pas les chéris
voila voila je suis en jouant pour
francs c'est vraiment des coups